hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast extracellular vesicle
detection and analysis via flow
cytometry I am Judy Oracle a Brutes
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's and sponsored by Beckman
Coulter life sciences Beckman Coulter
develops manufactures and markets
products that simplify automate and
innovate complex biomedical testing more
than 275,000 Beckman culture systems
operate in both diagnostics and life
sciences laboratories on seven
continents for more than 80 years that
meant Coulter's products have been
making a difference in people's lives by
improving the productivity of medical
professionals and scientists supplying
critical information for improving
patient health and delivering trusted
solutions for research and discovery
more information please visit Beckman
Coulter comm we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive we
encourage you to ask questions during
the event you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we try to answer as
many questions as we can you can enlarge
the slide window by clicking on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on e support button at the top right of
your presentation window or submit your
problem with the green Q&A button lower
left I would now like to introduce
today's speakers priscilla's Tok
Sebelius and John Digges
bacillus toxin Vivi's obtained a degree
in podiatric medicine from the
University of Wales
vassilis is first position was at South
County podiatric associates in the
United States from there he transitioned
to academic research at Roger Williams
as hospital a Brown University Teaching
Hospital in the pathology department in
2002 vassilis joined in growing Beth
Israel Deaconess Medical Center flow
cytometry core in Boston
there are his research interests grew to
stem cell biology where he became a
crucial member of the Harvard Stem Cell
Institute the BI DMC HSC I current
research interests revolve around small
particle detection and cutting edge
technologies John Digges obtained a
degree in biological sciences from Rhode
Island College John obtained
certification as an immunology
specialist from the american society of
clinical pathologists from there he was
recruited to academic research research
at Roger Williams as hospital in a
pathology and clinical immunology
department in 2001 John became manager
of the BI DMC flow cytometry Court in
Boston there his research interests grew
to stem-cell biology
landing him as a crucial member of the
Harvard Stem Cell Institute I will now
turn it over to you vasillis Scott CBDs
for his presentation good morning
everyone thank you for today we are
going to take when you speak about
extracellular vesicle detection and
analysis by flow cytometry whatever work
that we did is for research use only and
I am going to start by setting the stage
for John to to dive into more in-depth
information in regards to extra bicycle
for psychometric analysis by providing
an overview of what exercise exercise
our vesicles are and how we get to set
up instrumentation to be able to detect
those particles so it's always
associated vesicles are tiny vesicles
between 30 and a thousand nanometers in
diameter and they are released in the
extracellular environment from a variety
of different cells the type of cells
that we have it can be two mu cells than
treating cells linked for a red blood
cells cardiomyocytes
you
single feels and cells from different
tissues and organs recently we probably
some work that we did working with red
blood cells are looking at the diurnal
variations and we also have done
extensive work with cardiomyocytes
working at micron a 30 D and how it
least is a predictor of arrhythmias in
cardiac arrest and the sequence and it's
super simulation therapy the release of
babies has been reported in the
pathologies of cancer with illogical
diseases the methodological diseases
cardiovascular disease early metabolic
disease viral infections such as malaria
traditional for scatter versus size
scale measurement the threshold is set
to eliminate advance measuring less than
one micron hence all extracellular
vesicles are considered several degrees
small particle detection requires more
rational capacities the instrumentation
that we use currently we designed to
look at whole blood and hence we had
were focusing into lymphocytes monocytes
granulocytes and the red cells in
degrees we cannot tend to ignore the
past so the conventional analysis of
micro particles
TVs were regretted will regarded just as
a simple server degree or fragments or
part of apoptotic bodies and the
instrumentation was designed for home
blood cell analysis
platelets were the smallest considered
structure that thought they were able to
see with that was a trauma at the time
the way was optimized so the range was
between 1 and 10 microns and the flow is
that the poor scatter was standardized
for greater than 1 micron using the
photo dye or and the standard collection
angle of 90 degrees which with
instrumentation that we
utilizing nowadays we have more enhanced
optics with John joins gonna talk about
it later on a little bit in more depth
and a different way using photo
multipliers kmt's to collect a light
with a wider angle also the side scatter
added dynamic range but the science
gotta was also limited now we have the
ability to threshold from different
laser lines for size scatter and kind of
enhances dynamic range a little bit
manufacturer threshold was said to
exclude less than one micron in size and
adjustments allowed for about greater or
equal to 500 nanometers so that was
pretty much the limit that we were used
to looking at access area bicycles with
more particles on conventional floor set
on their specific cytometry standard
parameters for measuring these fees will
not establish this is still any problem
field we every day with many things
collaborating and sharing knowledge in
this field is very important so we can
get some kind of optimization in
standardization the techniques that we
use so they can be uniform as we measure
versus elevation this is a quick a
traditional former scatter detection of
particles forward scatter is a parameter
means of measuring the light scatter
less than 10 degrees as as a self passes
through the laser beam and the four
scatter measurement is related to cell
science relevant so a typical exercise
where Misco analysis with the four
scatter for the diode with limiters down
to 500 nanometers
dynamic range of the original flow
cytometry limitation the threshold was
set on the 488 size data and at the
lowest possible cell depending on the
platform that you
use always available at the time you may
be trainer or for scatter and/or side
scatter or size gather and fluorescence
and try to lower your first hole and
fight to really push the limits try to
identify those babies so trying to
advance the science and we try to do
carefully with the details so we need to
find a platform so we can set a range to
be able to standardize and be able to
detect those small vesicles so what we
did is we started by looking at dragon
green beans standardization is very
essential to achieving consistent
results and the program should be
comprehensive encompassing reagents
protocols in the configuration
qualitative analysis fluorescence
intensity units so what we decided to do
is to start with the dragon green beans
dragon green beads which we obtained
from bank laboratories but they're
really good for what we want to see we
want to set a range that we may be able
to detect those associated with vesicles
and that range would be the beats that
we use were between 192 nanometers and
780 nanometers in size the reason why we
use those is because the drug will bring
green beads on an excellent surrogate
floor for fluorescent
by using our 5 3030 filter with 525
bandpass and the different sizes that
gives us were able to set the
fluorescence and maybe back a and and
double-check the sizes in order to
optimize for small particle detection
so nano beads they are served as a
reference point for of course different
sizes of Pisa we use and and different
materials have different refractive
indices so it's very relative so you
have to be very cognizant when you use
repeat that means of the same size but
different material they will scatter in
different areas now we run the mix
tribal beads on our none of you we have
a more for xdp without purple not lots
none of unit and I'm all for us mystique
you here you can see the noise and you
can see the beads between 192 and 520
and 780 nanometers and the trigger on
the number view was a 488 side scatter
on the for scattered does have a PMT
alongside with another module and the as
soon as eq was a 480 x i scatter trigger
on on the plot that you see with the p1
mask that was provided by the company so
how do we initially try to optimize our
instrumentation so we get the dragon
drink beads which shown in kate them in
order to eliminate any clumps and it
needs taken together and then we take
the 182 is five 20s and 780 nanometer
beats and we dilute in the PBS and point
one percent tween 20 solution with a
final concentration of one point two
nine times s2 the 70 beats per
micrometer 780 nanometer beat we set the
voltages on the side effects on the
violet size Garrett inside scatter
properties from maximize signal-to-noise
ratio and resolution and we adjust the
fitzy voltage to maximize a thoraseal
the larger size is chosen first two is
for particle identification and provide
instrument ability to analyze less than
one micron then we proceed to
differentiate with $192 million beads so
we need to differentiate between the
noise and the particle we adjust the
threshold and make adjustments to
decrease the influence of noise we
adjust the game and then finally one
more step important around the 520
nominated beads to verify the separation
between the hundred 19 nanometer beads
and the 708 number so we can actually
visualize the dynamic rates or the issue
and the final step 2 is to mix all the
beads together and running through and
verify the ability to separate and
distinguish multiple populations we want
to make sure that recent propagating and
maximum separation of the populations
for determining the relative size
distribution of the matrix so the
initial district optimization we use the
gain and threshold settings which can be
adjusted maximize performance however it
strongly suggests that the single beam
confirmations we are quiet again - quad
for Quality Assurance purposes and the
instrument has been optimized and
templates insane and the settings are
saved for future reference for several
experiments the optimized settings is
the bar with size scale were said to a
long area parameter it was plotted
against the group 488 size data I can in
a log area and the blue size care
setting was at 350 units per game
the feature setting was at 370 units on
the game and the violet size Gator was
praised at 22
units gain and a threshold of 2000 so
here are mix beads on to the right do
you see me the noise actually in time
date so that we open a little bit more
to the right out of the way and then we
run the beads so we said I did basically
instrumentals and then we run the beads
on who super separation between noise
192 nanometers 520 708 now the nice
thing with First Bank bees is we're just
looking at the scatter there's no
reference in fluorescence right now but
John will show further down we can
actually I think must my next slide will
be referring to that as well we can back
gate from fluorescence into the scatter
and double check about the populations
of interest and here's the fluorescence
verification step we have the 7/8 inch
521 92s and the noise please note that
the gate that you see here on to the
left on the 192 is 520 to 780 these are
I'm gated events it's not back gated
based on fluorescence for us it's very
important to be able to if you have a
sample with fluorescence and the sample
we thought fluorescence it's very
important to be able to distinguish the
different size populations that you have
and we have been fortunate enough to
have instrumentation to do so so four or
five nanometer wavelength versus 40
nanometers of wavelength it's all about
to be we have the nice Cara the valley
scurrying and
so the me theory predicts that
scattering cross section of the particle
and thus is getting scattering intensity
it is dependent on the wavelength of
light the angle of collection the state
and the relative index of the particle
all other factors been people using a
sword illumination wavelength will
result in an increase in scattering
cross-section and thus more scattered
light and we'll talk a little bit about
the differences that we have between
those two and while we're using those so
we were very interested about the me
scattering of the particles and really
quick without getting to too much
details in regards to the physics the me
theory predicts the scattering
cross-section of the particle and that's
the scattering intensity which is quite
important it is dependent of the
wavelength of light in the ankle of
collections and the size shape and
refractive index of the particle so all
other factors been equal using a
shouldered lumination wavelength with
resolved with an increase in scattering
cross-section and that's more scattering
light which is good we want those
photons so we can see those little
particles so we decided to do a little
quick and dirty comparison between the
violet side scatter versus the side
scatter from the 488 MFI and as you can
see we have the side scatter gain at 350
and the violet side scatter gain at 22
and obviously the MFI between the
different types of beads will run 192
nanometer polystyrenes
5 2047 780 polystyrene and also will run
latex beads 200 300 and 500 nanometers
and as you can see the the new
fluorescence intensity on the violet
side scatter with a gain of 20
- it was a lot better there was a little
bit of which is kind of interesting
there's a little drop-off on the 520
polystyrenes and 300 nanometers Latex
right in the middle of the range
so I have a question that popped up and
says wonder how to distinguish the dots
are noises and not real vesicles well
there is no way to be able to
distinguish you are going to have
vesicles in the noise region you are
going to lose some particles vesicles
into the noise region unfortunately what
I have the technology or the capability
to be able to tease them out what we
have done we have calculated the
smallest size particle by using a
gradient differential of predetermine
particles running through our
instruments and we have determined that
30 nanometers is the lowest that you can
go looking at a flow cytometry with
enhanced optics so there's to answer the
question there's there's no way you are
not going to see every single particle
if that's that's where we are right now
maybe in six months a year in ten years
that will change and at this point I
just want to I just want to go ahead and
and give the stage over to John Digges
and he's going to dive in with more
detail into the instrument design and
give you a little bit of the science
that we have done and try to explain a
little more about small particle
detection in our instrumentation John
Thank You Priscilla's there's another
question I'm just going to look at it
and maybe we'll get to it in a second so
actually I'll answer that question while
I talk and hopefully it will answer if
not please feel free to follow up also
hopefully we don't have any more
technical issues I hope it's coming
through loud and clear at this point
thanks again miss Phyllis for setting
that kind of for us what we looked at
here in what this is just reflecting is
we did look at the violet side scatter
using the small saito flexbox our
original studies all were revolving
around the mofo xpp and the nano view
attachment we'll go into how that works
how we looked at the Saito flex and how
it worked and finally looking also at
the mo flow hashes HU and it's dual
Fouad scatter PMT and how we use that to
our advantage with some slight
modifications of course so what we
actually did here is that basically
let's see what the differences are our
mo flesh shows EQ we dealt with looking
at a 561 nanometer wavelength we came up
with this simply because well I guess
first we said meet theory we're going to
throw it out the window
secondly is on the EQ on a seven laser
system 561 happens to be the center pin
hole in the seven pin hole configuration
so we just figured more direct light
this was on collaboration with Jennifer
Jones from the NIH and so we both looked
at our instruments and came up with this
being the best kind of methodology at
the time we have found pretty much than
any of the lasers across the board will
give similar results when things are
done in a certain method to carry on we
then looked at violet obvious
on the saito flex and blue of our mole
flow XDP with the nano view for now on
we're just going to call them EQ nano
view and Saito flex for simplicity we
also obviously there's differences
between looking at avalanche type
photodiodes and a PMT modification so we
wanted also put that in so we have
different laser lights different
detectors and obviously tweaks in the
optics so what we did here is then break
down how does each one work so basically
our EVs on the Saito flex what we wanted
to do is take these guys trigger off the
violet because of what the still has
talked about before with me scattering
saying hey violet should be better
according to basically a half wavelength
type principle so 405 should allow us to
see things at the hundred to 200 they
use basic what they call in a fiber or a
photodiode system a long with this comes
lower noise detection higher quantum
efficiency so something as answering
that question something like a CF SC
staining of these extracellular vesicles
basically they'll internalize they'll
get cleaved and they will allow for the
green fluorescence to appear not so much
as you would normally think of CF SC and
the permit the premise of you know
looking at kind of a cell cellular cycle
proliferation so it does work this
should work better as it says the higher
quantum efficiency along with what
they're deeming as the wavelength
division multiplexing basically this is
a straight shot into the detector no
bandpass filters and you're just fiber
optically bringing the signal directly
into its the detector itself we tend to
like to look at things as you'll see
more from just a scatter perspective
and there's a reason for that we'll get
to finally we're able to control sample
speed that has a custom kind of fluidics
and so slower speeds means longer
interrogation as you know laser beams
are much bigger than the particle size
at this point so there is worry of
particle sticking together swarming
effects things of that nature that are
in publication on the XDP we with the
nano view so the Nano view
modular modulation that we've used in
many of our papers and in just other
webinars or posters or talks that we've
given what they did here is they
basically took in a spheric lens focus
the blue laser into a 200 micron pinhole
this wastrei laser light has is all been
collimated into one type pinpoint which
hits the enhanced PMT this reduces the
background the other way they did this
is it's a modified chamber so the
chamber itself is smooth instead of
having angles or squares so it's all
kind of in more of a horseshoe form
where everything is rounded and smooth
this doesn't allow for light to be
scattering all over the chamber Babel
was built by stealth fighter thank you
for some I wouldn't have thought of that
that's a good analogy they also took the
nine degrees that Vasilis mentioned
before and upped it to an 18 degree
detection angle so this allows more
light to be taken in from each particle
so by doubling that to the detector you
get greater signal so like we said if
you don't have high sensitivity you
won't be able to see these things in our
particular case we took the largest
available blocker bond that they had
which is approximately listed here as
the six point three degrees to twelve
point six set that at an approximately
45 degree angle obviously there's some
leeway there couldn't be precise and we
use the 488 side scatter even though
this isn't it
poets scatter we use the sides together
to increase the dynamic range and to
make more consistency but in studies
that we have done we have shown that the
side scatter and forward scatter are
giving similar results the EQ
modification gives us what we're seeing
here is the actual EQ modular modulation
it it has two different forward scatter
PMT's set on a beam splitter here 60 40
beam split and they give you a different
type mast they're called the masks allow
for different splitting of the laser
light the p1 was what we used it gave
the the maximum opening
we also found by taking completely out
the mask you've got a similar result as
it is a closed chamber so you're not
getting a apparent light from other
sources this is also where we've done
some cross studies with the NIH as they
also have the same configuration as us
so with Jennifer Jones we have done some
work to to show that these can be the
same type work can be done in separate
locations and with similar results this
is just a little bit more on what the
instrument is set up as with the seven
different unique mass we tested them all
and like said p1 I guess one on what
gave us the best kind of look the other
big thing is we can trigger off of any
of six different scatter parameters so
that's where we said 561 is what we've
always been using to try to keep
consistency but we've tried everything
from the 405 right up to the 640 having
all those side scanners allows us to to
play around and plot things differently
as you will see we're able to plot
forward versus side scatter width and
basically threshold out a bunch of noise
without having a major effect on the
phone with side scatter plot whereas
other ones as you threshold you will see
how things get cut
so our modifications on this is we
change the phone with scatter detector
so that we took out the beam splitter so
we were getting 100% of the light
through to the detector we chose the p1
mask as we test it all didn't have time
to put all that data in and then we use
the 561 for our triggering so how do
these all compare and how do we actually
see it well we went to what they call
pcs controls these are normal type
controls for DLS type machines and
basically we took the hundreds for
200-300 500s we did this because we
expect to get similar results the dragon
beads as we were looking at polystyrene
dragon beads compared to latex PCs
controls thinking the materials in there
attractive index are similar somewhere
between the one point four five and one
point five one we expect to get similar
results but we're taking the
fluorescence out so that we can see what
the machine can do on scatter properties
alone with kind of out the safety net of
having a fluorescence back this is due
to a lot of our groups just wanting to
look at things that are not
fluorescently labeled it would be great
if we could do that but we're given what
we what the researcher needs and we've
tried to develop a methodology to do the
science and see as many of these
extracellular vegetables as possible now
just looking at the PCs you can see here
from our EQ data we have very good
dynamic range and separation from the
noise or our noise to signal ratio it is
is exceptional I would say but adequate
for what we want to do the separation
between the twos threes and fives is
great this basically sets us up on a
relative type setup for for later stuff
we really realize biologicals compared
to these type samples are not
necessarily the same because of
refractive index but it kind of just
gives us a goal this is the Nano view
where you can see again signal-to-noise
ratio
is is great we have decent separation
between the three populations here
though you can see the noise because we
are doing a threshold off the side
scatter you get a little bit more of the
what looks to be this picket fencing is
called it's just bending of the data it
doesn't really know what to do with the
really low stuff so it stops to try to
slam it into the higher bins and then
finally we can look at what we got on
our site Oh flex and the site Oh flex
shows similar type stuff if you remember
the previous slide bacillus showed where
we had the noise here on the bottom with
the gate that was a little smaller than
we should have put it you can see that
we also have great separation between
our 200 300 and 500 s and good signal to
noise ratio showing that all three
methodologies had you know their
advantages in the long run but showed
comparable results here we just show
that in a more data format just
everybody likes graphs so we did that we
just compared the site of flex the name
of you in the EQ I know it says percent
difference of mean fluorescence
intensity but it's mostly just the Geo
mean placement of the populations
compared to one any another so between
the two and 300 is a very good
relationship between what the
instruments could show log decade wise
and it is similar throughout the 300 to
500 with a little less separation on the
site of flex in the hires which is okay
with us because most of us are
interested in the lower end anyways so
it's it's not really a big deal we
wanted to see that so a lot of these
questions that I'm seeing popping up
we'll get to hopefully at the end as
time permits but I was told we could
answer as many questions as possible so
hang in there low end resolution is what
we're really interested in is vasila
said if you get very clean clear
siphoned populations through UV
absorbance we could see down to about a
32
the nanometer in a heterogeneous
population from plasma this is not
necessarily the case as it's a little
harder to differentiate who is is what
and you'll see that in the end of this
talk how it dispersed the populations
are and as vassilis so nicely pointed
out there is going to be lost in the
noise there you know and we've seen that
as you will see in one of the advantages
of having either the Nano view or the EQ
is the ability to sort so what we did
here to try to check as we put here
we've done numerous times the EQ and
nano view to look at less than 200
nanometers that was our bread and butter
for a long time the Saito flex we wanted
to look at as more as a benchtop option
a little easier to use and for our
collaborators for to be able to do on
their own without the expertise of say a
shared resource laboratory in flow
cytometry so we took some hundred
nanometers controls we mix those in with
some 130 nanometer Sparrow Tec nano
fluorescence particles and basically
what we were looking at is okay can we
differentiate that closely related and
what is the bottom kind of resolution of
the particles so we wanted basically to
see is it still similar to our larger
sorters so we ran the 100 nanometers we
ran 130 s and like I said we then mix
them together and we'll get to the to
the bread and butter which everyone
loves pictures so we'll do the pictures
here in just a second so as we can see
here this is 100 nanometer pcs control
we can see it here in the expected area
this is compared to just running the PBS
that was used and also just the
instrument background which only gave
the population the dark black on the
basic left hand side so this is how we
knew that these
pop this population landed here we also
did that as a check with the florescence
because we want it to be sure not just
make claims here is the previous data
that we did on this is the Nano view you
can see the noise you can see the
hundred nanometers just above the noise
and then the split from the 200s same
thing on the EQ with a little better
resolution obviously here great
signal-to-noise ratio and separation
between the hundreds and 200s this also
took some some more modifications
obviously a little more tweaking on the
on our micrometers don't want you to
think that we just simply throw them in
and that was that clear when looking at
the lower end you make modifications in
order to see those typical populations
as you can see here if we would put a
500 in it wouldn't be on this particular
plot finally we then looked at 130 s and
the 192 's and you can see that they
don't really separate clearly unless you
use the fluorescence here in this one
area you can see the 130s appear as they
should have slightly less fluorescence
on the green channel compared to the 192
s and when you separate them out you can
clearly see where they come up on a plot
on the scatter plots which is in that
region which is then again assured us
that are hundreds when they appeared in
that region before was actually the 100
nanometer bees so what do we have for
observations up to this point what have
we learned basically what we see is that
our EQ our Nano view and a Seidel flex
give promising results and are pretty
similar across the board on looking at
beads for right now and you know these
are latex and polystyrenes we've also
done which the data is not shown here
using the apogee beads and so this is
from I believe they go down from 100 up
to a thousand
both fluorescent and on fluorescent
bundles so and those showed similar
results also but that was just recently
that we received those so we haven't had
time to put them into the presentations
we like the resolution and dynamic range
on all three this is allowing for more
capabilities during the analysis also
the Saito flex though in the Nano view
as you can see did have slight
limitations so being able to tease out
the difference between hundreds and 200s
or anything in between is not as easy as
it was on the EQ and in order to get
this lower signal-to-noise better
signal-to-noise ratio excuse me our
dynamic range did suffer so putting in
an actual fluorescence does clear that
up it does help but as I said with our
collaborators this is not always the
case and we just try to use what we have
to see as much of the picture as
possible so what we then did is grab
some of the biological samples we took
some plasma that had been
ultracentrifuge and thrown through a
gradient and basically looked at how
they appeared on the different machine
so here you can see it on the EQ as you
can see as we spoke on the actual
dispersed nature of the populations in
the plasma
there's many populations going on in
these extracellular
we've also tested and done the
microscopy to see okay is there little
proteins are there micelles and
basically we do get a very good
population of what they're calling X's
ohms at this point and have verify that
through AFM and cryo-em and different
even using like a Q nano I'm sure we're
losing like we kind of want to keep
reiterating we're losing in the noise
region but we also wanted to put some
other stuff here showing its comparison
to just a 500 nanometer
so we added that into all our you know
into the samples as kind of a internal
quality control this is off the nano
view using the side scatter trigger on
the blue laser similar kind of arcing
plasma profile and finally looking at it
on a Saito flex where we use the violet
side scatter versus the 488 side scatter
and you can see it gives more of a kind
of a vert diagonal plane as you're doing
side scatter versus side scatter but all
kind of similar results similar type
profiles and so we wanted to do it a
little further so we took some samples
that we had on a particular study and we
did just a simple comparison using the
violet side scatter and using the 561
side scatter on our EQ as you can see
here the results for the different time
tables that we did are very similar so
we have percentage-wise 22 23 55 57 and
then back to a 22 21
very positive data on an ongoing study
so we were very pleased with how these
kind of were showing the results pleased
with the different techniques and how
they all were comparable and gave
reasonable data okay sorry
so as a summary of going through so that
we have taught as much time as possible
for questions as they saw a lot of them
the interest in the characterization of
micro submicron particles or small
particle detection is very broad across
all of the different fields through
immunology and inflammation and
cardiology so we've worked with groups
doing you know cardiac disease farm
BOCES malaria and from red blood cells
vasila said diurnal variations
across the board just to see if when
sampling these V's if the time period of
day was important and basically we are
trying to establish a methodology across
different institutions and to get a
machine SPECT out for doing
identification and detection of
extracellular vesicles and obviously
there are many ways to do this there's
fluorescence there is scattering
properties all that flow cytometry
brings to the table along with looking
at things like a microscopy from atomic
the complex atomic force microscopy to
cry OEM dark field mentioned the cue
nano which uses a pulse resistance
methodology based off of culture
principles dynamic light scatter which
does has similar problems to flow
cytometry with laser based diagnosis of
these very tiny particles but even
that's coming very far with looking at
you know data potentials and back
scatterings
in multi collection optics the nano site
the NTA so that has I guess been listed
almost as a as a gold standard
previously for looking at extracellular
most insight to the actual
quantification of exosomes
but I'm a flow cytometry so my standard
is looking at these guys in a flow
cytometer ik method how can we do that
and so we have published just recently
some techniques and methodologies we
have a couple other papers in the works
with our collaborators at the NIH
working on these methodologies and I
mean there is a plethora of information
now in many different ways I guess to
get to the same type answer
and it's just an idea of what is giving
the most accurate and dependable data
and what can be used more broad spectrum
across different universities
institutions and stuff so we basically
have wanted to try to optimize the light
scattering principles we've looked at
different types of ways to do this
obviously there's also groups that have
looked at improving their light
scattering collections and even image
cytometry that will do so that are able
to check the fluorescence and in real
time and also give a picture basically
of these smaller exosomes liposomes of
us in the such so what does all this
still mean right we have more summary so
the other things are basically that if
we enhance what we have already if we
take and pay attention to the details
that was the the smiley face I guess is
looking at the details and paying
attention to all those details that we
can see particles less than 200
nanometers now that the the old paradigm
of looking at just 400 to 500 nanometers
is no longer and even though the
conventional flow cytometer has its
limitations
fluorescence can allow you to still do
things on your old instruments we're not
saying you have to throw them all out
but you also can upgrade them and do
things to pinpoint laser better focus
them to the particular spots slow down
your fluidics and also you know get
higher optical benches on them
and basically we looked at three
different things and we're able to look
at them all and see how they were
similar and the big difference though is
obviously an analyzer shows great
results but unfortunately it cannot sort
so we still love our sorters the EQ
especially to do
look at these give great dynamic range
and basically be able to sort out the
populations for further analysis or
downstream type assays such as looking
at RNA seek so I believe this next one
is just a reference list things that we
pulled from for this particular talk
today please feel free to do a screen
capture of this while it's up so that
you can familiarize yourself with all
the differing techniques and the latest
and greatest that's out there and
finally looking at how we've gotten to
what we've done we have as I said many
posters and papers to begin with and
different characterization methods
different ways to look at these
circulating micro particles in different
families and the latest being the
diurnal variations of the circulating
extra basic cellular calls so I believe
now the sillas and I will head over to
the question and answer portion and
hopefully be able to answer your
questions I believe right Thank You John
I can remind the audience how I ask you
questions and then I'll put all their
questions to you hopefully we'll have
time to answer them all so I want to
thank you both for your informative
presentations so before we get started
on the Q&A session here is how to submit
your questions you can submit them by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can and B
let me know if this is if this is the
one you'd like to answer first can you
use CF
effie treatment of self to distinguish
vesicles from noise due to fluorescence
yeah I try to touch on that and we'll go
back into it to clarify so CF SC has
found itself a place in extracellular
vesicle detection there are a few groups
that have published on using this
technique it is a good way to do it the
biggest problem with any sort of
fluorescence tagging is still the
ability to detect the lower limits so
you're now talking about having to
standardize the machine using mes F type
values and also maybe looking at things
on a single photon counting method CF SC
does work but it you're still looking
for an interaction with the cell so it
has to intercalate and then basically
lend itself to being cleaved and
responding so even in the older days
when they did the similar thing with the
phosphatidylserine and using annexin v
you were still limited by being able to
detect negatives versus positives so it
is a valuable technique also and by
marrying the two techniques we feel that
in the future it will be able to
encompass more of the population to give
more accurate results what composition
of particles was used to establish the
30 nanometer 30 nanometer lower limit
polystyrene latex something else okay
these were actually little proteins as
stated it was a group it's in the was
the paper that was a reference
previously the character issue of
circulating micro particles associated
with cd39 on ecto nucleotides so this
was out of a
Simon Robson's group here at the Beth
Israel Deaconess Medical Center and by
using the UV absorbance and then taking
life of the lipoproteins and then
labeling those with a cd39 Alexa 448 we
were able to look at them on the scatter
and then look at the peak intensity on
the 50 channel and the peak intensities
were able to look at the quantitative
results so in other words the more that
he actually sectioned off in a certain
line then the higher the fluorescence
peak was and basically they correspond
did exactly so by doing that we were
able to say okay you have a 30 nanometer
lipoprotein that is stained with an
Alexa 448 and we were able to see that
and then we confirmed it by the
fluorescence in bat gating in our
experience height and amplitude of
scatter signal is always better than
area surface integral do you ever try to
compare in your system yes
so area we used look basically we've
tried height we've tried area the
results are very similar most of the
time we are actually using height in
this particular one we just went because
we were looking at the three different
instruments so we tried to keep things
as similar as possible and the easiest
thing to do was to look at the area
parameter on all of them
this also due to other instrumentation
such as things like the influx of the
Aria where area is more prevalent so we
just wanted to be more across-the-board
but we do use height for most of the
stuff that we do we do realize that in
either one it's a half peak CV so you
know it's not as high B is moreover
through measurements or currently used
up
sorting purposes so we private
everything and we just as Joan said
wouldn't be across the board tried to
compare between different platforms just
to give an idea this is this is not in
the last year or the last two years
we've been playing with this
technologies and different ways and
forms and working to kind of tweak the
instruments with colleagues at Stanford
as I said the NIH in other areas even in
the Netherlands and Ireland to over
probably the last eight years to come up
with what we believe to be a methodology
that at least lends itself to setting
your machine for its greatest chances of
seeing a small particle detection will
the system work for easy from bio fluid
for example serum cerebral spinal fluid
yes yes we have done serum we have done
CSF it's just the groups that we work
with ten to do plasma as the day
especially in it with the cardiologists
we have done both samples from the
cardiac sinus and through the peripheral
blood because we wanted to blood works
the best as we're looking for how they
track through the system as everybody is
looking at the cargo that they hold and
how they interact in our cellular
communicator z' please clarify that
latex particles cannot measure absolute
size v these are eye index differences
that are mainly useful as a reference
material for QC and standardization
purposes yeah we did mention I think I
made a committed reference code a few
times in regards to this when I want to
opened up the talk and absolutely those
those ranges that we use those
beads there just rains it's not absolute
numbers you cannot absolutely hit you
cannot measure the size of movies based
on the beads it's just a range it gives
you an idea of the range where the
particles of the particles may be if you
want to do a really quick experiment you
can run some latex beads and some silica
beads of the same sizes and you can see
what kind of different scatters that
they have again it's just a reference
and thank you for bringing that to our
attention yes because there is no
problem
guard I just wanted to say that
refractive index wise we understand what
has been published is that the
refractive index of a in extracellular
vesicles somewhere around one point four
one and basically that's why I mentioned
the Apogee beads because they have a
mixture of refractive index of about 1.5
and other ones at a 1.4 to so this gives
you more of a generalized picture of how
they appear on your instrument and also
they're more the 1.42 is more comparable
to your biologicals in the fact that
they're right around the same now
granted they can go as far down as they
save 1.36 but we still don't exactly
know how their membrane reacts to light
and how the actual reflection appears it
could be like a mirror and as we see
this does happen when you can collect
the back scatter you see there's a lot
of back scatter in these type of
particles which would mean that there we
you know reflecting a lot more than we
actually first thought to be true could
you comment a measuring easy on a site
or flex that doesn't have a violet laser
would have helped at all to use a
fluorescence trigger in this case yes
without the violet I would try to use a
fluorescence based for the simple fact
that we have tried just straight going
fo it's got a versus side scatter
on these on a Saito flex the poet
scatter is extremely limited you in
other words there's no dynamic range off
the boat scatter if you've done this you
you can see you are very limited in that
aspect so mostly what you can what you
would want to do is probably a
fluorescence mocker versus side scatter
triggering off the fluorescence would
probably give you your your best bet if
you're doing this and so you know it's
it's a I guess the best way to put it is
it's a lot of trial and error
it's basically figuring out best
methodology for doing it on your
particular instrument and then going
back and looking at the also the other
technologies that are available to you
to solidify that what you have is real
particles are great as Vasilisa to kind
of set things and understand what your
limitations are or what your successes
can be whereas biologicals have their
own set of problems they're not always
spherical or broad shaped as we know
what liposome they're very squishy and
tend to come down through a flow cell in
many different configurations so as I
said it they have their own set of
issues that you have to deal with but we
like to show the beads as a how can we
actually get things going and are we at
least in the right framework in order to
look further down if you can't do the
beads obviously there's no reason to go
looking at at things that are in the
hundreds to 200 nanometer region on a
biological so connect restriction in
Colossae Wiegand where you going to add
a couple more things
oh no sorry it's just clicking on we
were looking through the questions
ourselves oh okay okay well here's
another one for you and this person
thank you for your presentation as many
have before can we apply dragon beads on
older Beckman saitama ters looks like FC
500 yes it's actually a very good paper
put out by
in the Marseilles group I believe so
Roman Rico Lacroix or there's father
Philly ponce Allah that the megamix type
stuff that have done work on FC 500 it
also might be a lumber song so there are
publications on exactly how to look at
it on an FC 500 and how the megamix can
actually help with this so we have done
it on NFC 500 we have done it on the
gallio's there are marked differences
between the two fluorescence is probably
your best bet when looking at an FC 500
the gallio's then took some stuff that
they had from old Qantas and yeah and
and we're able to open up also expand on
the what they call small particle
detection or they use the w2 or enhanced
wide-angle so it is feasible but like I
said it it's not optimal as we're
finding out those groups have been the
same ones that have published also from
FC 500 to gallio's and even some Saito
flex data now so they are helping kind
of mould and guide how the
instrumentation should be advanced do
you think in isolation technique for
exomes matters 4f ACS analysis oh yes
absolutely does and this is this is a
topic that we can talk about for hours
that's where you break or make your case
in the Gustav V detection what I would
recommend is go to our that urinal paper
and look into our isolation technique or
feel free to email us and we'll provide
a copy of the protocol that a group is
using we'll just keep this short it's
it's very very important another story
yeah ultra certification
is huge there's been years of debate on
what is the best protocol for doing the
ultracentrifugation and which
populations actually to take you know as
things pellet out is it that you know if
you take the pellets you get a lot of
different stuff at the end compared to
taking the supernatant how am I like we
said how are you getting a lot of
lipoproteins are you getting micelles of
cell fragments all these added type
things take the suits and cause some
problems we've also found in our paper
that tubes that are used are oh yes a
detrimental or a great success so using
different types of tubes have shown
shedding during the centrifugation
process and when you're starting to look
at things this small you can actually
see the pieces of the tube the plastic
that's come off
they act like polystyrene beads you can
also see things such as the dynamics of
water we've been able to look at the
ionized water profiles and any kind of
contaminant that actually gets in there
will show up and will give certain
populations it actually took us six
months to figure out that the tubes were
all bad and then to test a bunch of
tubes to find which ones didn't cause
activation or shedding why are you using
488 laser does it have a better scatter
we're not just using for da define the
token Mitchell we we created with a 561
we use the 405 on the side of flex and
on our none of you we're using the 488
because that's that's how the system was
built 48 was basically the the kind of
bridge between what me scatter dictated
as how low you could see so 48 should
give you around a 200 nanometer particle
size that you can see and what most
instruments were equipped with and so
when you're thinking of Fouad scatter
it's based inside scatter most people
think of 488 and Fourier triggering so
that's where
first when we work for propel labs to
try to come up with something they went
off the 48 and just instead changed the
chambers and changed the optical
configuration and now other groups are
trying different things and I mean we've
even heard murmurs of UVs and stuff like
that
so it all really depends there's a
there's a lot going on it's evolving
it's just that most instruments whether
conventional as they call them flow
cytometer or this new wave of
specialized instrumentation for exosome
detection they're all equipped with 488
so a lot of people were trying to do
that
do you recommend plasma or serum for
easy detection and do you recommend an
optic reputation before aphasia
I don't between plasma and serum there's
not a major difference once again prep
becomes the the biggest kind of
deterrent determinant of what should be
done so if you have serum samples great
if you have plasma great but it's how
you prep them and how you get out your
your EVs and we know between optic
purification there are papers that say
that is wonderful there are kits that
can be used for doing this and basically
it's what works in that particulate type
scenario we like to try to see as many
as possible and get the the entire
picture as far as we can so this is why
we use the scatter properties and look
at just those type things everything has
its advantages and limitations like
vasila said we can do probably another
five hour webinar just on advantages and
limitations of all the different
techniques which you know there are
papers put on out just by that if you
look on the International Society of
extracellular vesicles website each year
after the meeting they put out kind of a
notice of
the techniques and advantages and
disadvantages um you're out of okay uh
yeah so Judy if there's one or two more
we can do that and then we're actually
out of time as we have some other things
to do today to maybe look at more
exosomes so just let me know do you do
you think you have time for four more
questions we can do one or two more
please
we're looking through actually right now
just one at a time okay so quick and
easy ones are there was one about you
know is the device suitable for sale
sorting the two cell sorting ones on the
nano view in the EQ also I believe the
influx modified in modified in fluxes
and modify it modified areas can work
and we believe cell sorting is great but
again limitations in a really small
particle lodge drop at this point and so
techniques are used to basically then
siphon off extra fluids that's something
else that we didn't talk about and I
believe vassilis flagged a question
yeah we saw we saw a couple of things I
do agree with with the fact of ongoing
debate of refractive indices of v's I
said a lot of these things you go to one
of these meetings and you can spend days
just trying to figure out nomenclatures
and techniques and you know what it
what's the refractive index how do
particles relate to biologicals it's
it's good in the sense that it keeps the
field fresh and new and really exciting
well I would like to once again thank
the show stocks for these and John takes
for their presentations do you have any
final comments the film sent on on no I
would encourage everybody to take a look
at any flow cytometry as they may have
try the different beat arrays such as
dragon bees or pcs or Apogee beads mega
mixes just to get an idea if your
instrument it is is suitable for this
type detection or reach out to somebody
who may have something as a lot of
different groups we've learned have
these type X's ohms and stuff affecting
their experiments but don't know what to
do with them well you know even way to
start so reach out to them see what
other projects can be put forth and
collaborate as much as possible you know
use all the techniques that there are to
try to better the field and we
especially want to thank some of our
colleagues dr. Danielson dr. das dr.
girón
dr. Jones at the NIH Marty bigos and his
group at Stanford then I guess bill
Telford also down at the NIH with his
laser knowledge so and thank you again
Judy for for you know moderating for us
and everybody for joining thank you
thank you both I would also like to
thank our sponsor Beckman Coulter life
sciences for making today's educational
webcast possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
July 20th 26
tene you'll receive an email from LaBrie
saluting you in this webcast will be
available for replay we invite me before
that announcement to your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event to
next time bye
you